Hello.
It is March 9th, 2022.
We're here in Acton Flab Gas Stream
number
17.1 with Mao production.
And Mao is a product director
at Game Addict, a researcher
at versus computational phenomenology lab
and finishing a Ph.D.
in cognitive computing at U.
Q a.m.
So we'll have a fun discussion today.
Feel free to write any questions
in the chat during the presentation.
And we'll have a great time learning.
So thanks a lot for joining
this guest stream
and really looking forward
to what you have to share.
Yeah, thanks for having me.
I'm really glad to be able
to present this paper.
We've we've submitted it
and we're in the process of reviewing it.
So it's, it's a really exciting paper
that I'm hoping we can get out soon.
So today I'm going to try to go
through a lot of big concepts
and how they apply in active inference.
And then I'm going to try to explain
the nitty gritty of a generative model,
how to make a simulation, and then
what are the takeaways, limitations?
I'm going to try to keep this quick.
If you have any questions,
feel free to ask them
and I'll take anything as it goes.
So let's
begin with the main concept here,
which is confirmation
bias and conformity.
This this was the starting point
of our research
era we were
we were thinking with my coauthors,
which are Connor Hines, and definitely
to make us and Max Olmstead,
we were trying to think through
what leads people to see the world
in such a way that they are part
time, then
reconciling their view of the world
with other people.
And so we went back to the practice
of exchanging ideas, sharing concepts
and values between different minds,
which is the fundamental process.
It really allows humans
and then other living agents
to coordinate and basically operate
socially by sharing ideas.
Individuals communities can really pursue
their pragmatic goals.
So basically,
you know, get from is one of the goals
you might want to optimize for
they improve
their understanding of the world.
And then we notice
that humans are compulsory
cooperators
human individuals
and survive based on the predication
that they have access
and they can leverage the bodies
of accumulated cultural knowledge.
Over the course of evolutionary
history, humans have developed an
exquisite li sensitive capacity
to discriminate between reliable sources
of information from unreliable ones,
which seems counterintuitive in the age
that we're at.
But you have to understand
how far we've come before we got to the
to the arms race for this information.
So the epistemic process
as I just said,
it's really not real fluff.
Humans are not computing machines.
They're not perfect.
They're mostly use your
the process information
by reasoning to limit
the consumption of energy and facilitate
rapid decision making.
That's that's the basis of survival.
For example, confirmation bias
implies that all other things
being equal, individuals
would prefer sticking to their own
beliefs over changing their minds.
It's easier for them to potentially
change their
model less
than if they had to really all the time,
constantly deal with the volatile
moral of the world.
There's a lot of research
about confirmation bias
and its relation to cognitive dissonance.
We really don't like cognitive dissonance
we don't like feeling like
the world
is not what we understand it to be.
And when we're faced with information
that conflicts with our core beliefs,
we do in fact experience
cognitive dissonance
the tolerance for cognitive dissonance
tends to vary across individuals
that there are people
who can really tolerate
a wildly volatile world, and they accept
that they don't know things,
and they accept that they could be wrong.
And then there's personality types
who are much less likely to take
this dissonance and are more likely
to try to avoid this dissonance.
And so confirmation bias in this way
has a social influence.
Individuals will prefer sampling data
from their anger
and will seek to confirm their own ideas
by foraging for confirmatory information
from their in-group.
This ensures that
they have access to likeminded allies,
and they choose to belong to communities
where their deeply held
beliefs are promoted and shared.
This limits the kind of effort
that is already expended
in the forging of information.
This in-group delivery
also influences
how strongly information is integrated.
So if a group membership is important
for the individual,
they'll tend to integrate
way more information
that comes from someone they believe
believes the same things as them.
For instance, you can think of news
sources and Fox News,
so people it's not like people
from different islands
don't know what the others are saying.
They just tend to take
what their preferred channel says
and completely ignore what other channels
are saying, even if they've heard it
so the
confirmation bias is echoed
by another heuristic.
Now we're talking about conformity.
So that's the need to cohere
with the beliefs of one's in-group
so it's kind of a push and pull, right?
I want to be in a group of people.
We're like minded and I want to believe
the same things that I believe therefore,
going in a group of people who are like
minded is the best way to do so.
I also don't want to be kicked out
from the group
because the group has access
to a lot of resources.
That is very good.
For me, right?
It limits how much information
any one agent has to gather
to be part of a group.
It also increases
how much each agent distrusted
in group.
Agents can be way more precisely
predicted by the other members
of their group.
This is in part due
by Norms and Behavior Scripts.
We wrote another paper about this,
and generally these scripts tend
to benefit
the members of the group, right
that's why
they also want to uphold these scripts.
So being able to sample from the group
entails a continued relationship
to other members if I lose access
to this, I can lose access
to information, food, shelter, and
you know, it leads to difficult
if you want to read more
in the eventually
give you all the resources
so this is a natural stopping point
if you want if you have any questions,
if you have any
notes, you can share them.
It was really
powerful what you said about
the losing access to the group benefits,
especially from just the evolutionary
and ecological point of view.
What are the scripts
and how does this current work
that you're sharing relate
to the work that you had done
with narrative and scripts?
Yeah, so I mean,
the definition of scripts is not
perfectly shared across the board.
There's a lot of fuels that use it,
but the way that we've reviewed
the literature and run together,
we have weeks scripts and strong scripts
a week.
Week scripts are like cluster hours
of connected concepts
that tend to exist
with one another in a sort of.
Yeah, it's like,
it's like the building of a context
with naturally occurring concepts.
And then the strong scripts is how these
concepts tend to sequence over time.
So like for instance,
there is going to be an actual entailment
to certain events that they've gathered
the concepts together,
and then you're going to be able to
exist in a space like this.
And that's, that's how you, you norm
not only how people behave in a group,
but how they coordinate.
That is how you norm
how the simple reality begins.
Let's let's imagine
my script in this place
says that I must do this, this and that.
So I'm going to do this, this and that,
which means I'm not going to have access
to all the other things
I might have done
if my script had been a little different.
So that's one way that we we force people
to only look at a subset of,
of the available information
in a given space
Cool.
Then how did it relate
or how does this research
build upon what you had done
those few months ago?
All right.
So the previous paper had formalized
what a script means in terms of active
inference and basically
you with
you as an agent, with your mission
predict
what your
what you're supposed to do next.
So it puts a strong emphasis on your
on your available policies and the way
that your policies are shaped.
And then you're going to
tailor your prediction
there on the response of the nation.
So then you're going to get to
the sort of sequenced
patterns of synchronization
that reinforce each other, right?
So the more I get the right pattern
the more likely
to get good reinforcement.
And therefore, I'm going to,
you know, think that
this is the right pattern for this group
and this is going to shape the niche.
So much so that if anyone even wants to
or tries to enact something different,
they may just get so much prediction
error that, you know,
people just will push back on it.
And you're going to stay within
this sort of manifold that has, you know,
the center points.
Then that gets all the states in. But
the way
that we're using this research
to build on the previous one is that
we understand that
a script takes many forms, right?
The weak version of the script,
this really something
you could call an ideology, right?
So if you take all of my script,
really what this is, is
how do I map my observations
to my sticks?
It's really what it is, right?
And so this new research is saying, well,
agents are going to map
things differently
and thus they're going to end up
into different groups
by simple virtue of mapping
so differently that eventually
it makes no sense for them
to try to interact with one another
because they couldn't synchronize anyway.
So that's that's that's where this how
this builds upon all of these research
or success.
Yeah.
Please carry on.
OK, so
we've discussed confirmation
bias and conformity,
and we have discussed
how they mutually reinforce each other
so does this energy confirmation
bias leads
to agents being drawn to groups
that validate their opinion
and increase the probability
of behavioral and epistemic conformity
I believe the same thing,
and they form the basis
of the information spread.
So agents spread information
through media and through connections
to one another.
Given the network structure. Right.
And the spread of ideas
and behaviors serves local and larger
scale coordination.
This is very much
based on the work of Maxwell,
who has effectively discussed
how active inference
works across scale in nested
Markov blankets that eventually build
and become one another.
So similar norms
and coordination can be understood
as synchronization, which lowers
the cost of information flow.
This increases
the certainty of the message being spread
as well as the quality of its reception.
So just right there,
this increased certainty
the capacity to spread messages,
this quality of reception,
you can see already how this might lead
towards better synchronization, right?
Because more certainty means
you may have less attention
to give to one thing
in order for it to happen.
And you can start thinking
about other things
and start specializing in other areas
with the certainty setting up.
Right.
The message will be more intelligible
to group members
share the common set of codes
and agents were more likely to integrate
new information if it fits better
with their understanding of the world.
So one example of optimization
of message passing includes such that
they have been known to be heavy
carriers of information in echo chambers.
They were used in partizan weights
to reach people of similar mindsets
who understand what the hashtag means
and understand that this is a signal
for them to interpret
what's being said in the light.
They want to interpret it.
So the spread of the information
is optimized through hashtags
as to the mental linguistic
categorization markers.
That was a lot of words.
But really, really what it means is
just that you see a hashtag
we know what it means.
We know it has a lot of meaning
without having to have a whole text
for it,
which is great for Twitter, right?
So we
labeled our communities in this study
formed in the process of belief
sharing as epistemic communities.
Now, this term already exists.
It was already
used by other other fields,
but we've tailored it
a little bit to mean specifically
that our communities could share
and spread a worldview
or a paradigm
or normalize sampling behaviors.
Individuals in the community
are tied together by these practices
which reinforce the social signals
acting as evidence
for the shared model of the world.
So hashtag
the echo chambers formation is an extreme
example of epistemic communities
echo chambers
type people with similar views together,
and they tend to actively work against
the engagement with external sources.
They become very epistemic vulnerable
when members can really no longer assess
when an information is true or not
only having access to a few sources,
it limits how much information
can be gathered and relevant
sources of evidence really fall through.
The gaps and error will be propagated
because it goes really well, really fast,
and is integrated really strongly.
And so the people can no longer tell
whether it's false or not.
Then the the system is much likely to
to be more vulnerable
to misinformation and errors.
They'll have a difficult time to check
errors against anything, and most minds
in the echo chambers will become more
and more synchronized and thus
poised to make the same mistakes.
So that's a pretty,
pretty big chunk right there.
If you want, we can take a beat.
Yeah, I had a question.
What is a healthy usage of hashtags
look like or how do we
compress
information and context and perspective
in a way that might not have
some of these like threats or failures
that you're talking about?
So for the first part,
I have an idea,
but I've never read anything
that specifically said this is a health
you so all venture a guess.
But I'll start
with the second part of the question.
It will give you a good sense.
The way to keep communities
healthy is to force them to be exposed
to viewpoints they may not agree
with, sources that they're not
necessarily familiar with,
and that have more nuanced text.
So the more you expose people
to different
kinds of people,
different kinds of beliefs,
the more likely they are to depolarize
and be more open to possibilities.
That's just a fact.
Like we may think through experience. No,
you know what?
When I see my my conservative uncle,
my racist, homophobic
conservative uncle, when he talks my kids
grit and I stop listening.
Yes, that's true.
But you still are exposed to him.
You still have to engage
with his thoughts to some degree.
And so your reaction to push him away,
that's a natural reaction.
And, you know, you might actually do it
but if you're never, ever exposed
to his thoughts, you will never be able
to actually, first of all, really know
whether they're not true
because you've never engaged with them.
Right. So that's one thing.
So the guess about the hashtags is
maybe try to research hashtags
that are not part of your community
and try to reach people
who may not normally listen to you
in a language
that is potentially less polarized.
So if you really want someone,
the best example of this is,
oh, I see.
She's a YouTuber. She's amazing.
Natalie, when do you know her?
Not familiar right now.
I just the thing is, I don't remember
the name of her channel, but
she basically specialized
in philosophically deconstructing
conservative talking points in a way that
feel men them
and didn't
just destroy them on a sort of,
you know,
value based basis.
It was more like,
let's take these points.
Let's remove everything
that actually really isn't true
and take the kernel of truth in there
and understand it through their eyes.
And reinterpret
why this might actually still be wrong,
but not in a way that was demeaning.
And she reached a lot of people this way.
She reached a lot of conservatives
who were like, wow, OK, you know what?
I get it. And it was very effective.
So I think that's
the answer to your question.
Oh, carry on.
Maybe.
And I'm sure we'll be able to bring
active inference in, but it's awesome
to be just building the context
and seeing how there is motivation
and a perspective on the work.
Awesome.
So yeah, so one of the elements
that maybe will in fact
give you a good sense of how we're
bringing active influences is the concept
of volatility and habit formation. So
stability of the group is not guarantee
optimal inference in a changing world.
Requires integrating sensory data, right,
with beliefs about the intrinsic
volatility of the environment.
So environments with higher quality
volatility
change more often and thus have shorter
intrinsic timescales
at which the agent
has to keep updating their beliefs.
And conversely,
environments with lower volatility
require, you know, a longer time scale.
Start updating your beliefs
on the other hand, so
having a better ability to track
potentially important fluctuations
in information requires
to pay attention to smaller changes,
but increased attention to environmental
fluctuations will potentially lead
to increased sensitivity to random non
informative changes in the environment.
So that might be called a higher false
positive rate, right?
So it's important for agents
to to have the right
understanding
of the volatility in their environment.
One way to cope with volatility is to use
the coping mechanism to constrain
the uncertainty related to their own
behaviors via habit formation.
So here we are going to model habit
as a form of behavioral reinforcement
where behaviors become more probable as
a function of how often they are engaged.
So an agent has engaged
any given behavior enough
a habit can then be formed
and become hard to unlearn.
And this is important as we understand
both how parameters are set
in our generative model, but also
how echo chambers can form by habit
formation.
So no model behavior is driven
by information seeking,
which drives it to drive
that leads agents
to preferentially sample information
from other agents
with believes that they believe
are similar to their own.
So this
the way that I'm saying this
believe that they believe
is important in active inference,
because in active inference,
we're starting from the assumption
that we don't ever really know
things are kind of hidden from us
and we have to infer
what things might be.
So I never really have access to what
the other person believes.
I think they might think this,
and I'm going to try and further beliefs
based on some observations
they're putting out into the world
OK, now we connect them
let's start with
their inference.
So we're getting to the meat of it.
I'm going to do a very short introduction
inference if you already know, great.
If you don't, then
this is going to be very informative.
It's a biologically motivated framework
that rests on first principles
of self organizing.
And in complex adaptive systems.
So self-organization part
is probably the most important part here
because active inference is potentially
less interesting for rocks, for instance,
because they tend to self-organize
a little less.
I'm pretty sure we could actively use it
for a lot of the models. The
astrology, but in astronomy.
But effectively
what you're really clear here
is for things that tend to fight entropy.
So it's premised on the notion
that internal states
of any biological system
are statistically insulated
from the environment
that generates sensory observations.
So basically they have an inside
and they have an outside
and so they engage
in inference about the causes
of what gives them sensory states
to really behave optimally,
to keep fighting entropy
so biological systems entertain
a generative model
of the latent environmental causes
of their sensory input.
So latent because I don't know
really what causes it, I can only infer.
So it's a little different
from reinforcement learning
or reflexive beta algorithms
because actions
taken under active inference are guided
by these internal beliefs and themselves.
They are optimized
with respect of an internal world model
or a representation of the worlds
causal and data generative structure,
what we call the generative model
agents in
active inference represent their own
actions in their derivative model
by performing inference on both
hidden environments, states of the world,
and the consequences
of their own actions,
they can select behavior
which first achieves their goal
or fulfills preferences,
and second reduces
uncertainty in the agent world model.
So this is where we get to the epistemic
part, right?
I don't I want a certain
the world to be a certain way.
And then I also want to be less uncertain
about my own certainty of the world.
Being the certain way. Right.
So an agent's
main objective is to increase
their model evidence
and to reduce the threat surprises
that like it consider an agent
which is in the world.
If I want to predict myself surviving,
I want to see things
which are likely to make me survive.
If I'm surprised by something,
it's probably not likely
to make me serve survive.
And therefore it's
probably something I should avoid.
Like for right now, I'm in my room.
I expect the room to stay where it is
as it is.
This is good.
If there were to appear on my right
would be very surprising.
Probably very bad for me.
So processes like learning, reception,
planning, and goal directed
behavior emerge from this single drive
to increase evidence for the agents
generative model of the world.
So far, so good
so the agents
never directly act on sensory data,
but they change their belief
about what causes that data.
This is a course step in active inference
it consists in optimizing
these beliefs using a generative model.
It's also known as Bayesian inference,
or Bayesian model inversion.
This inference answers the question
What is my best
guess about the state of the world?
Given my sensory data
and my prior beliefs?
I don't come into the world
not knowing anything.
I have some basic beliefs about what's
what's going to happen.
And then I'm getting observations
and I make predictions
about what might happen
and then I act on those predictions.
This follows Bayes rule
where the optimal belief about hidden
or leading variable,
given some sensory data
is called the posterior distribution
if you want, and keep going into
that or it can skip that.
But but basically
you basically calculate
the probability of something
given something else,
the active inference perception,
the generation of a best guess
about the current
hidden state of the world is formalized
as the computation
of a posterior distribution
over some hidden states
and action
so the active part of active inference
is the computation of a posterior
distribution over policies.
Policies are just a sequence
of potential states
of the world. OK,
so now we introduce the actual model
is it is it clear so far?
Is the active inference part
pretty clear?
That's awesome.
You hit on many great active pieces
the only piece that really
I wanted to mention was the difference
between the observations
like what was said and then the hidden
hypothesized cognitive states.
It opens up a space between what happened
and why somebody said that
and so that
comes up all the time
in epistemic communities.
What is the author mean by those words,
or what are the person
mean by saying that?
And so that's why the context is
so important and active gives a framework
that might help us model
that kind of a scenario.
Exactly.
And I mean, this is this is exactly where
we're trying to go with this research.
Is that what right now
we want to model how people tend to
have different views of the world.
But the underlying phenomenon here
and we're going to try
to dig more into that is that
or the hypothesis
anyway is that there is a literal
different mapping between an observation
and a state,
which means for the same thing
being seen by two different people,
we're going to infer
two very different things.
And the funny thing is
then you come into the world of values
where it's a whole other scale,
so where we may
be interpreted the same thing,
well, we'll have a spin on it
in that spin being like,
No, no, I know what he meant.
I just fundamentally disagree with it.
And this is how we get into the web,
these descriptive webs of conceptual
spaces where
you see these these graphs of concepts
being connected.
But at some point there's a rift.
And, and that rift makes it
so that I value this.
You do not.
And we're still and so we can converge
towards understanding
without necessarily being able
to converge towards acceptance.
So this is the silver hypothetical
so. What one other note on on
what you just said there.
It's like the difference
between an orthodoxy and ortho praxis.
So what is the similarity
between conformity of thought
and latitude on action, vice versa?
And then in what way
are the systems around us like aligned
or not with our preference
about those features of systems.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
I mean, I feel like
this could all be encased in see, right?
Like we can interpret the same thing,
but my see is way over.
I don't want
so I'll explain to you later.
This made very little sense.
You brought
so let's introduce
the model a little more
we are
individuals, agents who share information
with one another, and they come to form
beliefs about their local environment
and about the beliefs of other agents.
In their community.
So to understand this phenomenon,
we leverage this the active framework
here, the organisms tend to minimize
the quantity
called variational free energy,
which quantifies the divergence
between the expected
and the sense data as a claim for
from this point of view, to select
an action is to infer
what I must be doing,
given what I believe and what I sense.
So there's been a lot of work
done in this field on active inference
to study social systems.
I'm not going to go over all of it,
but there's really cool studies
and I've just highlighted
a few here where basically
systems minimize for energy
give rise to large scale
behavioral coordination.
Much of the work,
though, is still theoretical,
so it'll be interesting to see how
experimental work and delve into this.
I know you're honest.
Margot are really Pythia and Max Lorenz
that are doing a lot of work on this.
I think Lars sends MIT
as well as doing some cool work on this.
So let me see
so at first glance,
it might appear difficult to model
phenomenon like confirmation bias
using active inference formulation. Why
because remember, our agents
are supposed to be guided
by the principle of maximizing Bayesian
surprise or silence,
which requires to constantly seek
out information that is expected
to challenge one's world.
Right?
Because the more surprises
that consume now, the less likely
I am to be surprised later right. But
information gain is subjective.
Epistemic value
or the Bayesian surprise or information
gain is always an expected surprise
from the point of view of the agent.
It's in relation to the agent's
set of beliefs or their model.
And because of this subjectivity,
the informative ness of epistemic value
or epistemic value of an action
can be argued it's
rarely far from the agent's expectation.
So taking advantage of this,
we give agents
what we refer
to as epistemic confirmation bias
by building a prior belief into the
to the model that agents are more likely
to sample informative information
from agents with whom they agree a priori
and is they
prior interaction is important.
So agents will travel agents
with whom they agree under the belief
that the agents are more likely
to provide higher quality information
so this is a key difference
with some stitching up in your models.
There's been a lot of opinion
models out there not allowed
with active inference, but definitely
a lot with traditional approaches.
And so the implementation
of bounded confidence
to motivate
polarization is usually hardcoded
in the agents ability to perceive
and thus update their beliefs.
In our model, polarization is motivated
by the positive effect
of confirmation bias and is thus directly
in the agents model of the world.
This allows agents to get more evidence
about their environment
if the information comes
from another agent that shares
the same worldview, they're implicitly
motivated in their generative models
to gain more evidence about the world
if it confirms their preexisting voice.
Also, agents normally in traditional
models can directly perceive
the belief state of other agents.
Right
directly perceived. That's the key here.
But in our model, this is pretty.
We believe this is unrealistic because we
we only infer
the beliefs of others and thus
agents do not have direct access
to each other's beliefs that the infer
the belief states
and change them through observation.
There's been a few recent papers
on that begin to build Bayesian models
of opinion dynamics which are motivated
by the Bayesian brain hypothesis.
The crucial point
that distinguishes approaches like active
inference and planning is inference
from the genitive Bayesian approaches.
The notion
that actions themselves are inferred
behavior is cast
as the result of inference, specifically
by sampling actions from a posterior
distribution over actions.
So actions are selected
in order to achieve goals
that minimize future uncertainty.
And to maximize a lower
bound on Bayesian model evidence.
So we're using this to supplement
the goal directed aspect
of policy inference which is driven
by the expected free energy.
And this becomes habits
when the prior over the actions
becomes inflexible.
Right?
So if the prior overreaction becomes
so strong,
it's just always going to be that, right?
This prior is learned over time
and in the context of opinion dynamics,
it can lead to a propensity
to continue sampling agents
that have been sampled previously.
So it's this idea of choosing action
through inference
in accordance
with the minimization of uncertainty.
It's a powerful modeling technique
because through the choice of policy
inference, one can encode various
social behaviors like conformity, habit
formation, hostility and indifference.
Here we really only did
habit formation because we had to force,
but eventually
this could lead to very, very powerful
modeling tools for social inference
so I can stop here
before I launch into the hypothesis
awesome.
With active inference.
Let's keep going.
Awesome.
So we have three opposites.
The first one is that we cast
confirmation bias, and active
inference is a form of bias curiosity
in which agents
selectively gather information
from other agents with whom they agree.
Epistemic confirmation can mediate
the formation of echo chambers
and polarization in social networks.
But we also believe that confirmation
bias, epistemic confirmation bias
and interconnectivity will will merge
and modulate the formation
of polarized epistemic communities.
Hypothesis number two
is we consider the effect
of agents beliefs about the volatility
of their social environments.
So we try to see how beliefs
about social volatility impact
their sampling behaviors
and which itself may interact
with epistemic confirmation bias.
So we hypothesize that beliefs
about less quickly changing
social environments
will increase likelihood of polarization
and hypothesis three
we hypothesize that we can model
selective exposure effects and conformity
through habit formation, which emerges
through Bayes optimal learning.
So we show that agents will begin
to sample only those who belong
to a particular epistemic community.
A greater learning range for information
will lead to clusters
within the network, amplifying
and quickening the formation
of echo chambers.
So the model
this is a multi-agent active
inference model
and the group of agents update their
beliefs about an abstract binary states
that represent two conflicting ideas,
and the opinion states about these ideas
each agent also generates an action
that is observable
to other agents
in the context of digital social network.
We're using the Twitter linguistics,
but this was
we basically tried
to replicate distributions
that were finding
previous studies on Twitter.
Over time, each agent of this
posterior distribution are beliefs
about which idea is true
and as well as a belief about what
a connected set of other agents
in the network believes.
So basically, what do their neighbors
believe and both of these inferences
are achieved by observing the behavior
of other agents.
Agents can only observe
the behavior of one agent at a time.
So they have to they have to
pick who they want to look at.
All right.
The model.
So I can go into detail of one,
but this is pretty
I know it looks like a lot,
but it's actually pretty simple,
these encapsulate observations, right?
So this is the observation about what
I'm tweeting, who I'm looking at
and what they're tweeting.
Right?
And then the Matrix is mapping
the probable ality of a state
having caused this observation.
So we have states about
what is is that true or not?
Is it ID one is 92
this is a bit blurry but
basically like which neighbor or I look
at and one is looking at
what do they believe.
Right?
So it's, it's,
it's pretty simple mapping.
Here you have D which is the priors
so what do I believe about the world
before
having any observation about the world,
then B is the transitions, right?
So how are the states likely to succeed
one another?
Here you have the policies.
So what kinds of actions in my likely to
take to bring about this this section of
of abstains and C are my preferences.
So then there are other terms,
but they're a bit more complicated.
So I'm going to go into them.
But basically these are the main
these are the main things
you have to know about agenda.
So I'm
going to skip real fast
because there were little arrows.
It's really more of a now just step
here.
Each agent, each active inference
agent in the multi-agent
simulation is equipped
with the same generative model.
A single agent
observes the action of other agents.
They form beliefs about an abstract
binary environment and then they choose
actions with good selves or observe
be observable to other actions.
The focal agent consists
of two simultaneous choices
an expression and an observation.
So basically what am I tweeting
and who am I looking at?
An agent can only observe one neighbor
at a time.
So at each time step of Google agent,
both tweets sits on a hashtag
and chooses to read a hashtag
tweeted by another single agent.
So here we're seeing hashtag again.
This is just linguistics, right?
We could have said anything.
Basically
these are numbers in a in a matrix,
effectively in a much more complex model.
We could have had them
read a hashtag and a sentence
and then try to infer
what the sentence really says.
We could have done something
much more complex before now.
The point was just to make them
try to infer a belief
based on.
I hope now we will rejoin
and then we'll continue.
Hey you there yet.
So sorry. I don't know what happened.
But we get all kinds of of surprises.
We prefer this is here.
You can reshare and just continue.
It is only a few seconds, but it was
it was great.
You know, when you say the right keywords
and then the Internet
short circuits, it happens.
All right, well, I don't see you anymore.
Oh, yeah, I'm here.
I'm here. Dory.
Oh, sure. It's me again.
Oh, yeah.
Awesome.
Actually, can I just go with this?
OK, can you see my screen again?
And I'm back. Is everything OK?
Great, great, wonderful.
We're back on. Where do you cut off?
Because I like to get talking
for a minute.
We heard observing one neighbor at a time
like Ethan, how you could have modeled
more complex interaction effects
with, like, multiple artifacts.
Yeah. Right. OK,
awesome. OK, cool.
Yeah.
So now let's explain the hidden stakes
so what are the stakes?
They're trying to infer as the idea.
So it's basically binary verbal.
I do want it to is do one true is 82 true
meta belief which is
the particular neighbors
beliefs about which of the idea is true.
So does my neighbor believe this or that?
The tweet
so what am I tweeting
and who should I attend to?
Which neighbor might?
And so this was actually very complex
Daphne and Connor did an amazing job here
because we wanted to change
the number of neighbors.
And so the matrices
had to grow in relation
to how many neighbors there were.
And they did it was it was beautiful
the way that they did this.
So shout out to Connor,
who's obviously a genius and me as well.
So I'll discuss control sticks.
So all states are which of the states can
my agents actually act upon?
So here it was the tweets,
so I can decide to tweet hashtag one
or hashtag two, and then I can decide
to look at neighbor one through ten
now observation
model adults, what can they see?
They can see their own tweets.
And this is important
because the thing is, often times
you have to have a sort of identity
mapping between your observations
and your states
so that the states can be taken
into consideration in the actions.
So here
you have to know what you're tweeting.
You have to know what your neighbor is
tweeting,
and you have to know who you're
attending to.
Right.
Pretty simple
now the likelihood so
PubMed
key in the generative model,
we have to describe
the likelihoods, the determine
how hidden states relate to observation.
Right?
So the entire a array
is a set of tensors with one substance
or for observation modality.
Each modality specific likelihood tensor
is a potentially multi-dimensional rate
and encodes the conditional dependencies
between each combination of hidden states
and observations for that modality
so we also have a transition model.
So the transition likelihood,
the dynamical likelihood in B lights
earlier the environmental dynamic
so how are things likely to change?
A higher value means that same idea
remains valid over time.
A lower value means the same idea
is less likely to be true over time.
So more environmental volatility
and then the dynamics of weather.
My neighbors are likely to change
their ideas of the world
then the next component here is
the the genetic models,
the priors over the observations
so in discrete, discrete
acts of inference,
we were presented these as vectors C, D
and E.
So goal directed action is motivated
by appealing to a baseline prior
over observations.
So that specifies the agents preferences.
So that is
the CEO was talking about earlier.
What do I want to encounter in the world?
What are the outcomes I'd like to see?
And those usually act
as kinds of rewards.
Then there's the price over
stated the initial time step,
which is the vector
it encodes the agent's beliefs
about the initial state of the world
before having made any observations.
And in the current model
we make the prior over control states an
empirical prior parametrized by the link
function denoted by the E.T vectors.
I'm not going to go too much into this,
but basically this implies
that the prior over those control states
corresponding to tweak actions
depending on the posture of the idea.
So basically
your agents are always going to tweet
exactly the same as they believe.
They're not lying but they could,
right? We could change that.
So how is learning under active
inference,
learning also emerges
as a form of variational inference. So
it's not an inference overridden
states, but rather over model parameters.
So the parameter inference is referred to
as learning because it is often assumed
to occur on a fundamentally way slower
timescale than hints in policy inference.
In this model, we use habit learning to
model the development of epistemic habits
so as I said, the, the
the tendency to resemble the same people.
And so they simultaneously infer
which neighbor
to attend to based on the prerogative
to minimize expected free energy.
And they also continuously
learn the habit
based on the frequency with which
they tend to ask their neighbor
all right, the actual simulation.
So in a given simulation,
we had several agents,
but we didn't always use
the same number of agents
we were very limited
by computational constraints.
We would have wanted to make something
much larger, much bigger to really model
an actual social media.
But this is very computational heavy
in the future studies,
we may try to increase
the number of agents,
but for now we tried to stay between 12
and 30 agents.
Again, same model for each agent
and each time step
agents simultaneously update their belief
and take an action,
each agent's observation
or function of its own actions
and the previous time step as well.
As the action to a selected set
of neighbors of the predecessor.
So not everyone is connected to everyone.
So I don't need
to see everyone all the time.
Each agent has a fixed set of neighbors
where the particular neighbors
are determined by
and let randomly chosen network topology.
OK, look
all right. So now local agents
with a higher estimate believes
the treats are more reliable.
They come from neighboring agents
the believe to share the same opinion
right so like minded people.
The inverse social volatility
is a parametrized focal
agents beliefs about the stock of society
of the social dynamics
the learning rate is associated
with updating the habit vector
over neighbor attendance and network
productivity
is the number the way that individuals
are connected to one
another is pretty simple.
So these are the parameters that we
tweaked during the during the simulation
you'll see that they tend
to inter interact with one another
and they're related to the
hypotheses. We formed initial
so this figure
is really cool.
It minimizes opinion formation
in a single active inference agent
and shed light on the relationship
between inverse volatility
and epistemic confirmation bias.
We use a simplified three agent
set up here,
so we just were trying to test something.
And each time step
the focal agent chooses to read a hashtag
from one of its two neighbors.
And the two neighbors are not actually
active inference agents here.
They're just they're just part of trying
to process their sources
of sequence of district hashtags and who
to who we have one or hashtag two.
And as you can see, higher
epistemic confirmation
bias induces a positive feedback effect
where the focal agent comes
to agree with one of its two neighbors
with higher certainty
as you know it,
it tweets the thing that it believes
even if it's exposed
to a sequence of hashtag over a hundred
time steps,
the agent receives the observation and
here below it support the heat
map shows that the temporal illusion
of the probability of sampling neighbor
one versus neighbor two over time shows
that it's clearly it clearly goes towards
the one he started it prior with
the new beliefs
and more metabolic volatility
meets a higher posture uncertainty
about the idea but it's still events
only leads to you know
believing in the same idea
you initially start to look
OK now
this is much
much more informative
as to the actual phenomena.
And you can see here that we have
two very interesting phenomenon
in census and polarization
they emerge when simulating the network.
We can see that
every agent is generated by the action.
The observations
of every agent is generated
by the actions of other agents
and so collected believe dynamics here
under different
narrative parameterization really show
that the evolving beliefs
of all agents about idea one
or about idea two in panel eight
and we see polarization
where two subset of agents
end up leaving in two different levels
of the idea of the idea
hidden states with a high certainty.
So you can really see like they go
very far, it goes one or zero
it's not it's not like point six
and it's really one or zero.
They're really certain in panels
being seen on the other hand,
shows consensus
where the whole network converges
on the same opinion
by the end of the simulation.
This really showcases
the rich phenomenology
displayed by collectives
or vector inference agents,
which validates or model really alongside
known opinion dynamics model.
And that was really able to replicate
distributions that we were
trying to to converge towards
journey.
Questions.
Yeah, maybe go back to the slides.
What kind of dynamics
might result in persist in diversity
or not just the absolute consensus
or absolute bifurcation.
But like you did mentioned,
you said you didn't see there
to be a continuum
of like people who aren't sure.
So what kind of parameters
or what kind of cognitive
mechanisms would facilitate that.
So lower epistemic confirmation
bias for sure
would would potentially lead
to more variety.
We would look at two network structure,
eventually lower
habit formation would definitely help
as well as you can see here,
and also higher belief
in volatility
so if you believe that volatility is
high, you're going to keep sampling
a lot of people
because you do believe that uncertainty
is going to continue arising.
Right.
So these are three parameters
that really lead to more diverse
and less polarized
beliefs and some ideas.
Because it's so interesting
how you captured like the two things
you can do on a classic social media
platform, which is decide who to follow
and then kind of at a finer scale,
who to pay attention to.
You know, it's also partially like
put in front of you
with the feed in the algorithm,
but also it's a little bit of agency
in like what you pay attention to
and who you follow at a slower time scale
and then how you act
and how that modifies
the epistemic niche.
And some people follow a lot
and act little and vice versa.
And different people's cognitive models
get up, get it in a different way.
Despite having access
to similar platform affordances.
So these are really great points
in future studies.
One, you might want to see
how the niece responds.
So right now that they're crafting
their niche is simply as a function
of who they're talking to. Right?
But you could also model
the algorithm screwing with you, right?
So the algorithm knows
you're looking for this.
It's going to cut some things from you.
And so you like for instance, one way
we could have done this is the niche
could have determined, well, OK, well,
you're listening less to this, so
I'm not going to cut that connection.
I'm just not going to let it be
broadcasted to you right now.
So that's
one way that the algorithm works.
Right?
It basically selects things.
It puts in your feed, even though the
people aren't gone, they're still there.
You see them less.
So that's that's when we we could have
done like a relationship with the niche
and as you said, yeah,
we could have model
different kinds of behaviors
for people who are more lurkers, right?
How do their beliefs change
if they're not showing?
So that's one way that eventually
we're going to be able to model
like influencers if they're people
who potentially broadcast
to a lot of people in a lot of the other
people don't broadcast as much.
So the beliefs of these people
are super influential
as opposed to believes that these smaller
people who are much less influence.
So that's
I mean, there's a lot that can be done.
It's really cool. But yeah,
people write about this.
The only problem in life is
there's not enough time.
But yeah, it's really cool.
So I'm like, keep going
because you're going
towards the cool part.
So there's an interaction
between epistemic confirmation
bias and network connectivity.
And here you can see a heat
map of the mean
polarization index across like 100
independent realizations
of the multi-agent opinion, dynamic
simulations
for unique combinations of network
connectivity
and epistemic confirmation bias.
So in the bottom, the selected plot
lines, two extreme settings of P
so p 02 and P 08 and
Y, which is a yeah.
So shaded areas around each line
represent the standard deviation
of the polarization
index across independent realizations.
So this is hypothesis one.
We investigate hypothesis one
or how epistemic confirmation bias
or Y and network
connectivity determine collective
formation of epistemic communities.
We systematically varied
both epistemic confirmation bias.
So 15 values
for epistemic confirmation bias
telling the range 39 and network
connectivity.
So 15 values for P telling the range
0.20.8 in networks of 15 agents
and over a hundred different realizations
of each conditions for 100 steps.
It's really a lot.
But the b the results are beautiful.
And so we were trying to see how higher
epistemic confirmation bias
in sports network might drive
the emergence of epistemic community
through the the formation
of belief clusters that are both dense
and far apart in belief space right
so they really believe different things
to assess the emergence
of epistemic communities or clusters.
We defined the polarization index,
which measures the degree of epistemic
spread in the system.
And so a high value of P so close
to one indicates more spread out
beliefs and implies
clustering an echo chamber formation,
whereas Louis implies the network agents
have similar beliefs about an idea or,
you know, less less diversity
or less polarization.
So it shows the
effects of varying epistemic confirmation
bias and network connectivity.
On polarization,
it is clear in the first column
of the heatmap that highly spread out
beliefs can occur it can occur at all
values of epistemic confirmation
bias in the presence of a sparse TV,
denser networks in general
reduce the risk of polarization
as seen by the by the drop off.
So how increased epistemic confirmation
bias can still counteract this effect
to some extent by marginally bumping up
the risk of polarization?
So this is a really interesting result.
But it comes back to what we were saying
earlier.
A dense network
means there's a lot of people
who you can see the opinion of
and who may not agree with you.
So you have more access to people's
beliefs.
Sponsored networks
means you're very quickly
going to fall into an echo chambers
because you're going to turn off some
some people you don't want to listen to.
And then you have no more
connection with these people.
So in this one, you see another heatmap.
So these are really noisy.
We're sorry about that.
We redid them for the for the reviewers,
but they're not ready,
so they're pretty noisy.
But I'm going to help
you make a little sense of them.
So here you have a heat
map of the polarization index
for 225 combinations
of inverse belief volatility.
So this hypothesis two and epistemic
confirmation bias precision.
So the above right heatmap,
if I'm pointing to the right, I
mean, yeah,
is the map of the Orient
demonstrated for 225 combinations
of inverse belief
volatility and epistemic confirmation
bias and below left
it's aligned plot of the most extreme
rows of the polarization heatmap.
So below right is the plot line
of the most extreme columns of the
attendance heatmap.
So for
hypothesis two, we model behavior
under different values of inverse social
volatility to see how we would interact
with epistemic confirmation bias.
We swept over epistemic confirmation bias
and social volatility, and we measured
the attendance rates and polarization
index for each configuration.
It portrays a complex picture
of the relationship between ECB
and inverse social volatility in the case
of high volatility over meta beliefs,
agents are driven
to periodically re attend
to neighbors in order to resolve
growing uncertainty about their groups.
You can see a higher average
re attendance rates.
Interestingly,
there seems to be an interaction
between re attendance rate and epistemic
confirmation bias, such that
in the presence of both high volatility
and low epistemic confirmation bias,
the re attendance rate is maximized. So
they'll they'll return to the
same people even if they have lower
epistemic elevation theories.
Because, you know, there is fear
they have high volatility.
The constantly thing, the people
are likely to change their mind.
So they're going to continue
to keep attending these people with
a little bit of a allure of volatility.
They're not the lowest, though,
because if if you have the low setting
volatility you're just not going to care
so much what other people think.
Are you just going to keep pretending?
So we speculate that the absence of ECB
makes the epistemic value
of attending to every neighbor
pretty much equally high.
And thus agents are going to continue
revisiting neighbors
sequentially with the attendance
preference for any given neighbor solely
dependent on the time lapsed between
the last reading of their last hashtag
so this is interesting.
It will lead to diverse
social attendance patterns so that agents
will prefer to constantly sample either
new neighbors with no particular neighbor
left or uncertainty driven resampling
so they can either sample everyone
or the same people.
But there but they'll
they'll try to attend to their neighbors.
A lot
OK, so here we have
the last hypothesis about the street.
We have there is a heat
map of the polarization index for all 225
combinations of learning rate and
epistemic confirmation bias precision.
So above right,
you have a heat map of the attendance
rate for 225 combinations
and epistemic confirmation bias.
So the parameters represent the centers
of the normal distribution sampled
from across trials for each configuration
below left the most extreme rows
the polarization
index heatmap and blue ride
the most extreme column of the region map
so you are trying
to see of the polarization of networks
via habits formation
follows hypothesis three
We slept over ECB for 15 values
timing the range 39 and learning rates
so 15 values chilling from 09
and the networks were pretty small
15 agents with a connection probability
of 0.4
and an inverse social volatility of
six and as before the same idea
so nine so
ECB was again
normally distributed with a fixed mean
and a variance of one so we we
we sampled from a normal distribution
and we eventually we lowered the
the the variance
and it gave us much better results.
But the learning rate was fixed
for the condition to really understand
what the effect of it was.
The learning rate incentivizes agents
to return to the same neighbor
by forming a habit.
This competes with the epistemic value
attending to a new neighbor
with a known beliefs.
This tested the hypothesis
that a higher learning rates
star have information,
increased polarization, and here we can
demonstrate that higher learning rates
and epistemic confirmation
bias interact to influence outcomes
at the collective level.
So higher learning rate
and this is more polarization,
implying the formation of more stubborn
epistemic communities in the network
ok, so
me you go to the takeaways
be awesome.
Let's ok.
So here
we showed confirmation
bias as an epidemic phenomenon.
Our agents have bias beliefs
and we saw that
ECB confers a higher weight
to information that comes from peers
and this can lead to a bad bootstrap
we find that opinion dynamics heavily
depend on that density.
This was not counterintuitive,
but the way that it happens
was a little bit counterintuitive.
The clustering phenomenon is exacerbated
by adding the capacity to form habits.
So this is important.
We found that ECB,
the presence of habit formation,
exacerbated polarization
due to the formation of echo chambers
or type communities of agents
that only read each other's hashtag.
And the contributing influence of beliefs
about social volatility to exploratory
social sampling leads us to consider
the role of norms in social settings.
If an agent is incentivized
via epistemic value or curiosity
to pay attention to neighbors
whom they are uncertain
about their social group
could be a source of constant surprise
as long as their beliefs about
the neighbors are constantly fickle.
So in other words, even in the presence
of a group of like minded peers,
you got burritos, I guess.
Pretty dumb modification.
The best kind of initial modification.
Yeah, I know, right?
With those brings moving brands
so we expect that increased beliefs
about social volatility refers
to repeated returns of peers
among one another.
OK, we have limitations in this work.
As I said, very low number of people.
We only model beliefs to believe
to exclusive ideas.
It would have been maybe more interesting
to have more and we would have wanted
to to notice the emergence
of similar
but distant subcommunities as well,
even if they're not already connected.
So yeah, that was it was all
that was all of it.
Cool work,
really fun to hear about
nice.
Well, if anyone's watching live,
they can ask any questions.
Otherwise,
what would you like to start off by?
Talking like when you present that for
what audience?
What did people often ask about.
And they ask the same questions
you ask them.
They ask,
What can we do about social media?
How do we factor in the algorithm?
What this can
how this ties into misinformation?
I guess this question
we haven't really talked about
the notion of misinformation
so that's something you're interested in.
Let's hear about it. Yeah.
So this is not misinformation.
It's kind of a tricky question, right?
Because you'd think
you'd think that misinformation would be
if it doesn't agree with us,
if it's about something we don't agree
with,
we cast it instantly as misinformation.
And in fact,
we tend to fall very heavily
for most sources of misinformation.
The only thing is
we fall for
misinformation that tends
to reinforce our view of the world. So
even if it's part
of a sort of conservative,
if you're if you're more liberal, more
I forgot the word
for not conservative in the U.S.,
but you're more left
if you're seeing some piece
that's been crafted by the right.
But it kind of
confirms your view of the world,
you're more likely to integrate it.
And this is this is pretty important,
especially when we're trying to
think about the Pew Online people and
people whose views aren't necessarily
completely polarized
but who want to view the world
as something they
they cannot fault. Right.
Something they have
they have control over
the epistemic value that they can gather.
And so they're being fed information
which feeds into that sort of meta
view of the world that they
they can understand the hidden truth
about the world.
And so this becomes a sort of tool
you know, where it doesn't really matter
what I picture you,
so long as it gives you this
sort of sensation that you have access
to something that others really don't.
And therefore, you now
understand the structure of the world
a little better.
Even if
when you take the whole thing
together,
when you look at the entire structure of
a conspiracy beliefs,
they're extremely unlikely,
extremely complex.
And one way that we've noticed
that we can
identify these conspiracy
theories compared to, you know,
true facts, they tend to have
a really interesting structure,
which is they're very sparsely connected
to very large elements.
But like normally in a true in
a true story and something that's real,
even if there's a lot of elements
or fields that are combined,
there's a lot of connections
among things, right?
Because because it's real.
So you can really you can see from a lot
of directions these real connections.
If you lose one connection,
everything doesn't fall apart
in conspiracy beliefs.
Those connections are so sparse
that if you lose
one, the entire theory
doesn't make sense anymore.
So it's it's that's
that's the kind of structure that we see.
So it's kind of sort of
you can see how
this would have epistemic value, right?
Because everything is so surprising
and uncertain that people would like
feel a lot of value
from accruing all this information.
Right.
So I think that's where we fall
into the bad bootstrap.
But there are other kinds
of about bootstrap, like
let's say.
So I don't want to I don't want to make
any community feel like there
being targeted or that
or that I'm being negative towards it.
But there are is
like let's talk about a cult right let's
think about a cult who started believing
a very niche set of beliefs.
And the the way that they do this is by
cutting off contact everybody else right.
It's much easier for me
to instill a belief in you.
There's nobody else to tell you
with the screens bullshit.
Like, what are you doing?
So one of the first thing is
they tell you to cut off contact
with a lot of people.
They reinforce the beliefs constantly.
They punish anyone who dissents because
that's how you reinforce a belief.
And then
you find them in
these sort of communities which are like
very only locally functional.
And if you take someone out of that
community afterwards,
and you put them somewhere else,
they're like
kind of lost because, well,
that's not how the world works.
Like they they're
they need to re learn a lot of things.
They need to
develop behaviors that are distinct
from their previous belief systems
that allow them to exist and, you know,
be humans in an already pretty complex
civilization system.
That was very interesting
about the resilience of the meta view.
So how do we
use active inference
to study these different phenomena?
Like how do you connect the nodes
and edges from the graph,
the generative model,
the cognitive model?
How does that visualization
representation connect
with like the phenomena
that we want to model.
I mean, that's the
part of the standard question, isn't it?
That's what we're working on
at the Computational Phenomenology Lab.
I have a theory, but it's not like
it's still being developed.
But my sense is
you're going to start treating
events as observations, right?
And you're going to start treating
so you're a node,
you're here in the graph,
and everything around
you is a sort of observation.
And you're, you're trying to determine
layers in the graph
which become states, right?
So you're going to move across the graph
by trying to predict
effectively what is the next state
and try to see if this new thing
that you're going to observe matches
with state you're trying to see. So
so that's just how you
move in the graph and then
the way that you're going
to establish what is
true or not.
So that's one way to do it.
There are other ways, right?
There's also swarm beliefs and stuff.
But like one way to do it is, well,
how much can I predict from this note
how much is actually connected
to this node?
And if if we take this structure again,
like the the graphs
which are sparsely connected and don't
allow for any connection to be lost,
you're going to start seeing that there's
going to be a lot of dense connections
between concepts
and it's going to be very easy for you to
sort of find your way through the graph
and be like, well, I can go there
and I can go there and I can go there
and try to make predictions
about the next potential nodes.
Given these two that you or these three
that you already have right I have these
three things and I know everything
because it's densely connected.
I can go there.
It's easy, and if I go there, I don't
lose any connection to anything else.
So that's one
way. Another way to do this is
agents are going to start
forming beliefs by observing
real life or reality,
and agents who have a lot of observations
about the world
are likely to, you know,
have a more accurate model of the world.
So the more they make predictions
about things that eventually happen,
the more we can give them
a reliability rating right?
So like this person sees a lot of things
one and two, when they see something,
it tends to happen.
So we give them a high rating
and then you know, the agents
talk to one another and sort of
like coordinate their beliefs.
And eventually
there's going to be this dude over there
that, you know, says Green and
everybody else says, right, it says red.
And it's like, well,
you know, the probability
of this green being true,
like there's a high surprise there.
The kicker is there's a high surprises.
So we're giving it
a lower reliability rating.
But if it does end up happening within
the value is
you know, is much higher as well, right.
Because we reduce
a lot of their usual free energy here.
So like
I think that's that's how
we're going to get to these two things.
Combine with the graph leading to
the nodes that you can connect together.
And the agents with reliability ratings
that swarm towards a true belief are ways
that we can integrate these things.
I think
or the first mode you had
I kind of wrote down, it was like dense
connections, ideas that have grounding
you know, good maps for territories,
more stable territory,
more effective map.
It's like in a family, if you went to
someone else's family, reunion,
you should be too surprised
that any given two people know each other
because there's kind of a coherence
or there's a prior about the density
of that network.
Whereas
if the network is very sparse, then
the coherence of it is susceptible
to single facts being wrong.
So you kind of point out to like
where a thread will be tied,
will this person do that person
that this money was sent here?
And then it's like
if even one of those things weren't true,
then the whole contraption is fallacious.
No. And then
and then like the dense connections
have an element of conformity to them.
Because you have an intrinsically
validating world
model
like the epistemic network of epic cycles
and that way of predicting
how the planet's moved
and then you have insight from outside
that goes against the conformity
bias, the prior,
but that can be how the community
can move into a new space.
So we can't have like just novelty
driven, like simply different is better,
but we can't have simply
the same as better
yet puts us in this active
inference situation, which is why it's
so cool to see epistemic
modeling like you have all done.
There's something really interesting here
about
the optimal space
around which you start.
You know, computing
the right amount of information.
So Mark Miller is working on this.
Alex Keefer is working on this as well.
I know that we're working on it
with also Alexandra, Syria through Lara.
So there's this whole group we're working
on, like what is the optimal computation
space?
Right.
And so this is this is
really the question you just posed.
Should I stay exactly where I am
or should I try consuming error?
And I think that's the beauty of groups.
And this is where we sort of fall
into what
what a group is
in terms of the marketplace, right?
So in the inner spaces of a group,
you'll have people
who are less likely
to start consuming error.
They're just like,
you know, they're just staying within
what's being done
and that's stability, right?
And then towards the external parts
of the group, there are people
who are more connected
to other groups, right?
And then who can can start
consuming ever.
And this
because the internal parts of the group
are very densely connected to one another
because, you know, they're an in-group.
This error can be passed in like
it can be consumed
in a way that is efficient for the group
to deal with through this
like sort of blanket.
So the real question becomes
like what's an active state?
What's the sensory like?
Yeah, a state
at the level of a blanket for a group.
But you could start you can start
to conceptualize it as like,
you know, your influencers
and your lurkers are like the lurkers
consume information
and the influencers promote information.
And then this whole thing becomes
sort of like there are people
who just consume what this one news says,
and there are people who just like
push out information and then maybe
they take a little bit of information,
but they're like, you know, there's
this vast network of people
who are like like, you know, people
who are like 90,000 followers,
but they themselves are all three.
So, so, so then there's this, like,
sort of layering of people
who listen to others.
And so the smaller people
who have less followers,
they're still connected to one another.
And there's degrees of through which
I think
information is passed and consumed.
And so what Mark Miller is trying to say
is that the computational optimal
is where you compute enough error
that you continue to
to grow
in your sort of fitness landscape.
So you're still learning about things,
you're still discovering,
but you're still stable enough
that no error is going to topple you.
Right?
So because you have
all these other people here
who keep your group relatively stable,
you know,
that consuming a little bit
isn't going to destroy your group.
It's like if it's like, think of a
republic, you'll like what we know.
We're in love.
This new metamorph
is not going to like break or shut up.
So it's good, right?
So that's that's
I think what allows like this
sort of large scale coordination
among groups is that
there are people who are less specialized
in consuming the error
and who can only do this
because there are other people
who ensure there's resources
being produced for them. Yep.
Or two thoughts or
one that core to periphery
or fringe continuum.
It also happens like in colonies
where there might be a brood chamber
that is the most homeostatic controls.
And then there's like a periphery out
to like kind of a lobby or an antechamber
where there is a lot
more like in and out.
And then of course, there's
the interfacing with the external world.
And so then there's analysis
with tracking of like where the ants go.
And so there will be some who's
continuum, who's distribution
spatially is more like the top parts
of the nest or just the entry room
and a little bit in
and there might be another one
that spends more of its time
towards the core and spends.
Then it goes a little bit out.
But that last piece you said, like
what roles
contribute to colony
or epistemic community
stability or collective open
mindedness or resilience?
Like those are such critical questions
that people frame qualitatively
every day.
And so it's just really cool
to have the conversation and open it up
to many different perspectives
about what roles do play in communities.
And then try to use the model
to follow up and
describe complex situations
rather than like constraining to what
communities can be
or how they can regulate.
Yeah, and there's something beautiful
about active inference here, right?
Because we could like
we can literally potentially
measure or, or predict
what might be an optimal state
for a group given the free energy
that the group can consume.
Right.
So if we can understand
how this consumption of error
can be distributed over the group
or at least can be absorbed we can say,
well, listen, we don't need to destroy
your, your to or not group.
All we need to do
is give you a little bit,
you know, like enough in the right
distributed areas.
So then you guys integrate on wrong
and potentially shift
without us having to further push
and potentially even polarize.
Like one of the worst things you can do
with one of your current family members
is antagonize them because
then they isolate and they're gone.
You're never finding them again.
Like they will.
They will be lost to that thing
which will consume them.
And this is and it's not just true
for, for, for, for fringe groups.
It's it's true for a lot of groups.
Where we're like
we rely on that community for survival.
As we said, there's a lot of communities
out there who need to stay tight knit
because it's beneficial
for them to be tight knit.
So let's say we're like a city, right?
And there's nothing wrong
inherently about being a city.
And what you want to do
is to try to prevent a catastrophe.
Right.
But we can't
we can't all be researching the types
of catastrophe that might happen
and like, someone's got to,
you know, make bread, right?
So so you start having these people
who you can
predict over time
that I don't have to think about this.
I'm going to have to pay attention
to this scale
because I'm paying attention to this.
And I know that they can rely on that.
So my model of the stable makes it
so that my role is super
clear and allows for others
to make these predictions.
Right.
So I think I mean, it's
not fully, fully realized yet.
And there's a lot of work to be done.
So but I feel like,
you know, we have it's there.
It's right there.
Here's something
that kind of makes me
think about like the city
is enabled by specialization
and all these other features
what are
epistemic infrastructure projects
like?
What are the thankless or thankful jobs
that people do like moderation,
governance, care for themselves
and for other participants?
Like what are those infrastructure tier
roles where it's like,
this is building the road?
So we we have to contextualize
how well this shop does
in light of the effort to build the road,
the community that contributed there.
And so it kind of like opens up
the idea of attribution and community.
And it's like very generative space
yes. I feel like the
it would be
would be difficult to say
that there is a very clear distinction
in any given infrastructure.
Right? So like
every
field has
people who innovate,
every field has people who
just stay on tradition
and we feel has people who just provide
like it's not it's not just like bakers
just provide right?
There are people who innovated bread.
There are people who think of new recipes
or think of new ways
or try to bring the same recipes
to different parts of the world.
So like it's
more distributed than that, but
I really
I really do think that these structures
kind of self emerge racial like
we all kind of have it.
Not necessarily I'm going
make that Brooklyn thing,
but I do believe that there's
a natural instinct to
to try something new.
Once you have the certainty
that shit
isn't going to fall under you, right?
And because we have
this sort of distribution of like
people who have more or less money
and people who have had past experiences
of having more or less money,
they kind of tend to focus.
And so it naturally sort of synchronizes
into,
well,
you know what, I was poor my whole life.
I want to be careful.
I'm not going to go crazy.
And that's why, you know, the fallacy
of the entrepreneur who had like nothing
and he became something like that is
that is bull.
Like, it is so easy to being entrepreneur
when you have barely anything to lose.
You know, the notion of risk
in capitalism isn't true.
You know, they can do it because to them
the risk is minimal.
If I lose everything tomorrow,
I can do it again.
So there isn't really a risk.
Whereas if if little lady over there
who has like 20,000 in her bank account
decides to put everything in a business
it's a real risk.
It's a real risk.
And I
obviously she's less likely to do it
because like what happens to her children
if she loses everything,
you know what I mean?
And so there's going to naturally be
these tiers of people who because of the
their states face.
Right.
So the probability of them continuing
accessing resources over time is is these
less spread out
they have to stay and concentrate
on this.
And by virtue of doing this
they also keep producing
value and resources
for people who tend to accrue this
and thus have more leeway to, you know,
try it out.
You know, I mean,
there's a reason
that it's so easy to go to university
when your parents are rich.
Like, obviously,
if you if you parents have the means
to support you you're going to try
and continue studying longer and longer.
And it's much harder
if you have to support yourself.
It's not impossible,
but it's so much harder.
So anyway,
so yeah, capitalism.
Well, to connect it to active inference,
you kind of brought up
the situational risk sensitivity
and how that relates to someone's
experience and their situation.
And then in active inference,
the policy selection
for whether the binary decision
to go to this university
or go to some other path
or a continuous policy,
it's broken down into that pragmatic
or kind of outcome
or goal reward orientation
as well as the epistemic.
And so what happens when people
don't have to have anxiety or find out
epistemic about how they're going
to get pragmatic reward for their action
and how
does that move us beyond the sort of like
web to engagement maximization
relationship with platforms
where there's a very specific generative
model, generative process relationship,
and it's based around
like a behavioral summaries
of the person's time spent on the site
or like their spending or something
like that, versus
like taking the cognitive reins
and saying we want to have lower anxiety
and we want people to be exposed
to different perspectives
or some other preference for platforms
that's specified
using an active inference framework.
And there's a lot in there
so I'm going to try to
think of a think of
the generative model, always like
generative models aren't
one scale, right?
There is scales and scales
and scales and scales and scales.
And what happens when you when you go
across scales is that you're on
your states at one level becomes
the observation at the next level,
and then it embeds an image,
it embeds OK,
and then the embeddings can sort of
like again track into one another.
So I'm here and there's the bear.
So I'm going to stop focusing on you,
which is a higher level.
I'm going to focus on directly
this right now,
and there's the bear
and I'm going to focus on the bear
but eventually the bear goes away
because, you know,
I was having a hallucination
and suddenly I can go back to a higher
level and start monitoring other things
and notice, OK, well, you know what?
This lasted a long time
and maybe I should be cooking
because I'm going to get hungry.
So I'm going to, you know, slowly
navigate the scales of where
where I'm supposed to put attention
based on how
the free energy is
is rising at a given point in this form.
I'll say
for the web or for monitoring
or for resource attribution
what am I really trying to do?
What I'm trying to do
is to make sure that a person
never has to feel
they're constantly putting out fires
so anxiety, is that right?
Anxiety is the constant belief
that you're like teaching everywhere
and you have to pay attention
to everything you're hypersensitive.
So let's let's lower that.
Let's let's feel like you can start
like giving a little bit more attention
to a longer time frame
or even a shorter one.
But just on the moment, because
like all of the parts of your model,
I'm pretty certain
there's not going to be a foreigner.
So like I have certainty across
all my scales and I'm going to start
paying attention to just this. No.
And like, I don't need to,
you know, give too much my mouth
how do you do this with monitoring?
Well, with monitoring, you're like,
look, given this trajectory right now
and given this personality type and given
like what we know already about her,
she's going to freak out
in about 5 minutes about X,
and I'm monitoring this.
So before she freaked out, let's
give a little reminder about this or like
actually through iodine or whatever,
let's start
something like my dream is like
in the morning, I wake up,
my breakfast is like started
like nobody starting it for me.
It's just starting.
So, you know, I do my my health predict
the kinds of things I'm likely to need
so that eventually I never, like,
ever have to feel like I need to pay
attention to anything with too much like
which one's uncertainty is going to rise
anywhere try and sort of question.
Exactly. But I feel like
I'm going in that direction.
There's the
preparing your breakfast
when you wake up and there's sort of
the cybernetics 1.0 version,
which is we have a prediction
about what time you're going to wake up,
and then we're just going to do it
like setting the thermostat.
We're going to just prepare it for it
to be ready at this time.
And this is kind of taking that
physical biofeedback layer
to another level.
But also, what should we epistemic
we forage for in the morning?
How do we experience that sleep
wake transition
in a way where like we wake up
and sort of like sharpen
or become more vigilant
and focus on the things that matter
and that have impact
and at the end of the day, sort of
have some unwind
or some sort of relaxing process
so that we can move into a healthy sleep.
There was a
there was this like, I'm
watching a lot of YouTube lately
and what's YouTube
it's like
there's this one dude who tried
to replicate a Billionaire Morning.
Right?
It was it was striking with
the billionaire does in the morning
in which is basically like, I'm going,
I'm doing all this shit to make my body
feel better and all great.
And then he did this stuff
to think about who he wanted to be today
and what kind of qualities
he wanted to embody.
And it's like,
yeah,
I got to think about not missing my bus
or whether I'm going to freeze my ass
outside or whether I might get fired
if I get late. Like,
do you see what I mean?
Like, my concerns, my direct
epistemic concerns in the morning,
vastly different
from what that do have to care about
because everything that I'm talking about
is certain about like he has no qualm
about it does not care. Like
so how might one sort of shift this?
Well,
I feel like there could be structures
that we could put in place
in order for someone to not feel like
they have to feel that.
But also
maybe a focus.
I know it seems hard to say,
but maybe a focus on the things
that he has to focus on
would potentially limit
the sort of
you know,
constant
need to feel like
you need to put out fires.
So let's say that I'm a I'm
a smart interface and I'm like, well,
this person
needs to be certain about these things
because their life has X constraints.
Well, maybe we're going to do
is give you X reports and look,
you don't need to worry about it.
It's there.
You have that information.
Now, what about you try to think about
things that are longer scale.
What about you
tried to think about things that
if you had nothing else to care about,
you'd start thinking about.
So, you know,
maybe these are the sort of epistemic
foraging that would lead people
to a slightly more peaceful life.
But maybe I'm
coming from a very privileged base
and maybe this is completely unrealistic.
So you'd have to ask people who
are much less privileged.
I have a different view
on this on this question.
Awesome points
just in our last few minutes, like
what are you going to continue
to work on or what are you excited about?
Or What do you want to talk about or ask
anything you want?
Well, I mean, you didn't
you mentioned your paper.
We never got to it with time or.
Sure.
So with a handful of coauthors,
we wrote a paper about
using active inference to study
specifically
the epistemic community of science.
And so we as a group read and shared
your paper on epistemic communities
and then took the idea
of like this epistemic entity.
And now we've seen act of inference
entities be at different scales.
That's several years
and many like different things
we've talked about there,
including the narrative scale.
And so we thought, well,
how could we model
the scientific epistemic ecosystem?
How could we do a systems description
of the scientific ecosystem?
So like the entities, like the person,
but also the lab, the university,
the Dow, in the case of
decentralized science, are like web three
or open science
how do we model the active entities
and for the active entities,
eventually flesh out
a cognitive model
like you've presented today,
but also include
the informational entities
which map not onto the adaptive active
inference agents,
but the mere active inference agents.
So we can still model
the paper as like an entity,
but it doesn't have any policy selection
that it can engage in where
or like a code
can engage in limited policy selection
when it's used by computer system.
And so the goal was to
develop
an ontology, the IOS, the Active Entity
Ontology for Science that would be able
to link up natural language descriptions
like I sent a message to my friend,
person friend sent a message.
So have the natural language
representation in with the graphical
flowchart representation
kind of like a social network
of different kinds of entities,
including the informational ones,
and then be able to connect
that to a simulation architecture.
But so sorry you cut off those.
Oh. So OK.
So you were going to try
and simulate agents using your ontology.
So basically
so the first AOS paper from last week,
we focused a little bit
more on the conceptual
and the history of decentralized sense
making
and history of science
and an introduction to Web three and deci
decentralized science
and then sort of our ongoing work
and collaborations are to go
from the flowcharts that we kind
of sketched out in some of the figures,
like a funding motif or an information
sharing
motif or a communications motif
into a simulation
that uses
the active inference entity model
you out.
You're willing to talk to Maxwell
about this like he's been trying
to think about how communities
react to active inference specifically.
And this this makes me feel
this makes me think of like Atlas
Shrugged,
like how there's this, like, core
and then people test out the,
the external hypotheses
until they reach the core
or if they don't read the core
and expands.
So there's something really cool there.
I can't wait to see more of this work.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I hope that we can continue
strangely attracting and intertwining
and including
just collaborators from different
backgrounds in the discussion,
as some people who are listening
might be hearing about active inference
for the first time
and might be connecting
with like a community in US
that likes to do this
kind of modeling and framing.
And also there's people
who might be more familiar
with the active inference modeling
and hopefully this like brought
their attention to a really important
and contemporary case
and of course excellent recent research
yes. Was doing
interdisciplinary research for the win.
Or anything else you want to add.
On know we've covered a lot of ground.
I know, I know.
Seriously, the time goes fast,
so thanks a ton for joining.
So you're out
bye bye.
Bye bye,
Bye bye.